yeah I want to start kind of a 10,000
foot view of just I think a lot of
entrepreneurs especially earlier in
their careers don't understand that this
may be the most important factor right
it's just if the idea is time has come
type thing maybe talk a little bit about
through your experience both in starting
a company at the wrong time and also
starting one you don't come at the right
time with the Facebook platform stuff
like that yeah so if you if you use the
word timing you know it really goes back
to in my opinion for pedestals but
people talk about product market fit
product market fit is essentially just
that it fits within a certain time frame
and then you have a product that is
working how do you quantify that in a
market that has demand for that product
how large is that market at that time
and then what's the team behind it that
substantiates those two aspects and I'd
say the other pedestal in our opinion
that people kind of forget about is the
distribution of that product into that
market and and that's another piece
there I would say you know the the
timing really equals product market team
and distribution as a whole if you were
if you want to look at as a formulaic
perspective and the you know the the
products that I were I was building and
my colleagues were building you you can
say that either the timing was off at
the market wasn't ready for it or the
product you built just wasn't working
before the market that existed like it's
kind of either/or and I would say all of
my products had a failure of one of the
two at any given point when we were
first starting around it where you know
the market was fairly saturated with the
ton of the same types of products so
what you were building wasn't any
differentiate it was a commodity so we
call that kind of red ocean markets
right where you're just building the
same thing it doesn't feel monopolistic
it doesn't feel like there's a unique
value proposition unless there's
something really unique and sometimes
unique means distribution but a lot of
companies don't have that either but
when you're starting off from scratch
you know say zero to one you don't have
distribution you're trying to figure out
what's the wedge to get that
distribution in in terms of how do you
evaluate that right so like I'm gonna
stand
who actually build a this company and
I've got this idea how do I evaluate is
this the right time for the product yeah
you know the what I'd say is who [ __ ]
knows right I think the part of that is
that there's a certain amount of risk
that your underwriting in the beginning
you know maybe it's a vertically
integrated SAS play into a certain type
of market that's never seen software are
they ready for not who knows maybe it's
in market that's not the United States
it's outside so it could be energy you
know real estate insurance it doesn't
matter I think there's just a certain
amount of risk capital that's needed and
a certain amount of risk attribution of
founders and teams that start with yeah
I've got this idea I think have this
problem that I can solve let's just get
it out there and see how the market
reacts and so so I'd say there's a
certain amount of risk capital for that
and the types of people and partners
that you want there's no data at that
time especially like let's just say you
and I are starting a company the two of
us or and we maybe we get two to three
people to act on top of it what we're
really doing is we're just building some
sort of prototype we're building
something that has capital expenditures
towards some sort of our wine that ROI
might be nothing is that hey we just
learned that this doesn't work or we
just learned that the market doesn't
exactly want our product this way we're
seeing all these demand signals to go a
different direction
let's build in that direction and that's
typically what you see for a lot of
companies it's really rare it does
happen though but someone says that I
have this unique inside I'm gonna build
this product and then I'm gonna be able
to sell it what typically happens is
they'll make that pitch and then they
come out with the product and then they
start tweaking it for their customer
tweaking and tweaking and tweaking it
until they've hone in on it sometimes
those companies start off as services
which is what we all know some of what
SAS has really turned into and either
that's top down mid market or bottoms up
but you know the the main thing I would
think to do is that you know there's no
real data in the beginning you got to
have some sort of keen insight and then
as time goes on and especially in
today's day and age you do have data
that you that are
you're collecting on how your customers
are interacting with your product and
and and the beauty of software products
are is that there's a leisure to it
there's breadcrumbs of how people who
use it and that's actually where we come
in is that we have like this guide map
of what it looks like to be a healthy
company for your industry at your stage
and life cycle and here's how you should
measure yourself against that or
benchmark yourself against that and if
you could do that then you know where
you are the quadrant or gradients of
healthy to unhealthy it's kind of like
you know you're getting ready to run a
marathon can you run it